buongiorno a tutti beh pensavo di essere
emozionato è invece molto peggio
io mi trovo in uno di quei momenti dove
la vita ti chiede di fare un bilancio
capire dove sei come sei a volte anche
perché sei così e io sono in uno di
questi momenti perché quest'anno ho
raggiunto i 40 anni non li dimostri
riporti benissimo grazie e a 40 anni
grazie a un algoritmo ho scoperto
diciamo una formula matematica che è il
motivo per cui mi hanno chiamato qui al
a dx che a 40 anni non hai più vent'anni
capisco la vostra invidia nella mia
preparazione e quindi ho analizzato un
po chi ero e cosa facevo a 20 anni e mi
sono accorto
analizzando un po le scelte che ho fatto
quando avevo vent'anni che non so se è
successo anche a voi
ma le prime scelte le prime decisioni
che facevo oa me andavano tutte dritte
verso i 15 anni ho fatto un concorso per
dj ho vinto ho cominciato a fare la
carriera del dj ho cominciato a girare
il mondo a 18 fatto un disco ma è andato
anche questo disco e ho cominciato
mia mamma contentissima e maestra
elementari vedere suo figlio che fa il
dj giro era proprio una soddisfazione
veramente forte però le cose mi stavano
andando bene le cose mi stava andando
bene e a un certo punto ovviamente ho
iniziato la mia carriera di errori
ovviamente cioè non è che questo è
normale però quando cominci a fare degli
errori
ti arriva sempre una una mano sulla
spalla abbastanza dovuta che spacco
senza corpo proprio certi arriva una
mano e ti dice vai tranquillo stefano
ricordati che sbagliando si impara e io
con questa frase qui insomma l'ho
sentita di ha sempre con questa mano
terrificante ho visto troppi walking
dead comunque cioè questa mano che mi
che mi tocca la spalla e mi dice vai
tranquillo stefano
sbagliando si impara con questa frase io
mi sono accorto che ho iniziato nella
mia vita a concentrarmi ogni volta che
dovevo fare una scelta mi concentravo di
più sul come non sbagliare
invece di concentrarmi sul come fare le
cose esatte che sembra la stessa cosa ma
non è proprio la stessa cosa è infatti
io reputo e ogni sono ricavato questa
mia filosofia di vita che sbagliando si
sbaglia e ne sono anche molto convinto
perché è vero che se io da un errore
posso capire come fare la volta
successiva una decisione corretta
è vero se ci fosse la casualità che non
ci sia una decisione vuole un'altra ma è
impossibile perché qualsiasi decisione
nasce in un contesto diverso c'è un
ambiente diverso non potrà mai essere
uguale a quella precedente
anzi vi posso dire una cosa per me ogni
volta che sbaglio è un pugno nella
pancia mi mi mette un po più di tempo
per fare la decisione successiva e
quindi sono entrato un po in crisi
perché ho detto ma se accumulare
esperienza potrebbe essere una delle
caratteristiche che li fa sbagliare di
più sono andato un po sono andato un po
in crisi
vi dico la verità però cosa è successo
che un giorno la mia vita è cambiata e
ho avuto la fortuna che la mia vita è
cambiata in uno scenario davvero bello
di quelli che ti ricordi in autogrill
che è un posto meraviglioso dove ti deve
cambiare la vita perché in autogrill
non so se vi è mai successo io mi fermo
in quel reparto e solitamente è vicino
agli occhiali da sole in plastica ci
sono i libri di marketing fantastici
come fare google in sette giorni
se non hai un garage non puoi fare una
startup tutti questi libri che io compro
tutti ovviamente e in uno di questi
libri però lessi una frase che a me
davvero cambiò la vita che fu per avere
qualcosa che non hai mai avuto
devi fare qualcosa che non hai mai fatto
io ero dico il mio camogli perché è
successo un po di tempo faccia delle
motori camogli e lessi questa frase è
per me fu davvero un un raggio di luce e
decisi di applicare subito questa che
per me era la mia formula nuova di vita
ho detto provo subito a sconfiggere
quella che era la mia nemica di sempre
la mia nemica storica per me è la mia
nemica storica è la routine per anni io
mi sono infilato in questa lotta per
cercare di vincere la routine
a volte ci riuscivo ma poi ci ricadeva e
allora ha detto aspetta provo a fare una
cosa diversa
provo a pensarla diversamente perché
quando voglio uscire dalla routine
non so come mai penso sempre al macro
allora caglio lavoro vado all'estero
cerco sempre di fare un qualcosa che
arrivi una bomba nella mia vita ha detto
proviamo invece a cambiare le piccole
cose ho detto provo a trasformarmi la
mia routine in una routine meravigliosa
cioè non solo non sono più come nemica
ma diventa la mia migliore amica ho
detto sai cosa faccio io provo a
diventare un eroe del quotidiano e sono
partito con delle stupidaggini
apocalittiche del tipo io ho fatto una
settimana ho fatto gli oscar della
brioche perché ho detto se le brioche e
un elemento che si deve inserire in
tutti i giorni della mia vita cioè che
se posso dare questo accesso alla prima
brioche che capita e ho fatto una
settimana a testare tutti i bar vicino
al mio studio
tu hai fatto le presentazioni con il
video e tutto ha vinto la b
vivace il cioccolato del bar italia e
quello diventato il mio il mio bar o
applicato questo modo di non dare per
scontato e cambiare le micro cose nelle
telefonate nel rapporto con le persone
quant'altro e ho cominciato a vedere
davvero dei miglioramenti fino a che è
successo un po di tempo fa su questa
scia
ho detto faccio una cosa che facevo 15
anni fa ovvero provo andare ad un
appuntamento in provincia di milano
sembra quasi veramente un test di quelli
tosti in provincia ma senza il
navigatore
ho fatto una giornata vintage ma trovo
senza navigatore
ovviamente io veramente ciò il senso
dell'orientamento di una lucertola
quindi ho detto parto un'ora prima
non so perché è venuta la un certo però
parto un'ora prima ho detto e non mi
nascondo che sono andato un po in dubbio
sull'esperimento che avevo fatto perché
perché non solo
arrivai tranquillamente a destinazione
ma arrivai anche un quarto d'ora in
anticipo e quindi non capivo questo
questo rapporto che stavo cercando tra
obiettivo e percorso poi invece
analizzando cosa mi era successo capi la
grossissima differenza di quello che
aveva fatto
il fatto che non avesse utilizzato il
navigatore mi costrinse a fare un
percorso dove ero altamente stressato
dove non riuscivo a tenere il volume
della radio alto perché come se il
volume non mi facesse vedere le strade
non è una sensazione stranissima non
rispondevo al telefono perché ogni volta
che sono al telefono terrore era cattivo
come una bestia ok e quando sono
arrivato all'appuntamento
ho stretto la mano la prima cosa che gli
ho detto posso andare in bagno
e quindi ho capito che cosa mi serviva
il navigatore arrivare puntuale no mi
serviva per raggiungere il percorso no
il navigatore
l'obiettivo finale mi doveva servire per
crearmi un bellissimo percorso non può
essere il percorso a il servizio
dell'obiettivo ma per me personalmente è
il contrario è il contrario perché io
penso che senza un percorso meraviglioso
l'obiettivo è mancato anche se l'ho
raggiunto e quindi il il l'obiettivo
finale deve essere il primo punto per
cercare di costruirmi un percorso
meraviglioso perché mal che vada anche
se non raggiunge l'obiettivo finale
comunque ho fatto un bel percorso però
loco cioè mi sentivo ho fatto un
ragionamento c'è veramente volevo
fondare il ted ho detto guarda che il
ragionamento che ho fatto
ok è vero ho detto porca miseria non ci
ho più vent'anni ho detto pensa se
avessi fatto questo ragionamento quando
avevo vent'anni
sai quante scelte quanti percorsi avrei
fatto in modo diverso quando vedo i
ragazzi così ho detto ma dovete capirla
stacco staccate il navigatore
fate qualcosa ok però avuto una fortuna
che mi sono trovato a fare questo tipo
di chiacchierata con una persona che
aveva più del doppio della mia età è
ovviamente il l'argomento è stato il
tempo io gli ho spiegato tutta la mia
arringa e lui mi fa stefano ma ma tu
quanti anni hai
allora mi ha ascoltato ha detto che c'è
o no mi fa quanti anni hai
e mi fa e io gli faccio 40 e quanti
soldi hai se quanti soldi ai 50 euro
mi fa no scusa forse non hai capito la
domanda mi fa quanti anni hai 40 e
quanti soldi hai e gli ho detto 50 euro
stefano quanti odio covati da un cartone
a genio al dunque e gli ho detto perché
e mi fa ma scusa stefano io non ho
capito una cosa stiamo parlando di
ricchezza
il tempo e il denaro sono ricchezze non
l'abbiamo deciso noi ma non ho capito
una cosa ma perché quando ti chiedo
quanti soldi hai mi dici quelli che hai
e quando ti chiedo quanti anni hai
mi dici quelli che non hai più io ci ho
messo 6 7 minuti per capire poi però
quando ho capito ho detto pazzesco è
vero cioè la mia ricchezza sono i soldi
e ciò che ancora o che posso ancora
avere per fare delle cose che non ho mai
fatto ma è lo stesso con il tempo era
pazzesco io mi trovavo a 40 anni che
avevo vent'anni non solo a dire un sacco
di vent'anni
e il bello di quando hai un sacco di
volte vent'anni non è la quantità di
scelte che puoi ancora fare ma è il
fatto che tutte le scelte che devono
ancora fare sono bellissime per una
caratteristica che che le unisce che non
le ho mai sbagliate perché le devo
ancora fare
e allora io ho detto pazzesco ma se il
tempo quindi viene gestito da questi
eroi del quotidiano dove cominciano a
cambiare ea fare delle cose diverse nel
micro nelle piccole cose
con questo tipo di visione
ho detto cos'è che potrebbe succedere
potrebbe succedere che riusciamo a
sconfiggere quello che secondo me è uno
dei mali
più grossi quanto meno che a me affligge
ma lo vedo veramente in tutti chi è
quella stramaledetta situazione dove
capisci il valore delle cose solo quando
le perdi io questa legge non la sopporto
io non posso capire il valore di un
amicizia quando la perdo non posso
capire il valore di stare un weekend coi
miei genitori quando non potrò più fare
questa cosa non posso accettare questo
tipo di malattia e non solo
io non mi accontento di capire quando è
il momento in cui sta succedendo che è
già un buon passo
io mi sto accorgendo che sto vivendo un
momento che poi racconterò quello è già
un buon punto ma quello che io vorrei
fare quello che vorrei fare è eliminare
il fattore casualità dall'equazione
della felicità perché se io penso in
questo modo
arriverò un punto dove me ne sto
rendendo conto che sto per fare uno di
quei momenti che racconterò io mi sto
rendendo conto che sto per fare la mia
storia e quando farò la storia quando
riuscirò a fare quel momento sarà un
momento bellissimo per tutte le persone
che mi sono state vicino per tutte le
persone che mi conoscono anche per le
persone che non mi conoscono ma quando
tu sai che stai per entrare nella storia
ci sono 48 secondi quei 48 secondi prima
di fare la storia che quelli quelli sono
tutti i nostri grazie